so one thing that we did there last time
was we went a little bit too high I
think so I think what we need to do is
we need to rotate ourselves laterally
sooner basically but everything else
look good so let's go so I'm gonna turn
right away
in this direction as hey George good
enough pilot but he can help
son of rockets stout
just send them okay now notice that we
are slowing down again now speeding up
that's not what that is because we've
lost the thrust but because we didn't
have the additional mass slowing us down
that we didn't waste as much time so to
be doing that so we're going in nicely
the right direction now we only have to
get to sixteen thousand four hundred
ideally we want to get both levin tax
food but the same you don't really want
to have to go sideways in the answer
because that's obviously a little drag
you want to get as high as possible for
you also due to conservation of angular
momentum and force which is applied the
edge of the orbit is gonna have more
effective talk about that later
so how are we looking oh no I didn't
mean to do that Jordan I'm so sorry
can we oh no this is bad
hey Jordan I like
oh my god okay this is that oh wow okay
oh well you know what I think we're
gonna be alright you know you're just
gonna take this huge Rove it out like
what I did there was ice I pulled the
stage this is the static coupler before
I was ready before children was ready
and we were just being pushed along by
the rocket I couldn't move us because
we've got a sodding great rocket moving
with us all right well a she looks like
that's pretty bang on a guy was worrying
over nothing right that's got to be able
to top of it surely
oh come on that's really nearby I mean
yeah we're like that for half of it but
you know oh that's that's that's some
bull right there that's we are
definitely over the top of that I've
even lost my science Oh what is this
we've been to space tone you're the
jolene you're the first first one of us
to properly get look how happy is he's
um
Jordan McGonagall you're the first
person to go to space from the YouTube
space program I hope you're very proud
look how round kerbin is it's a shame we
didn't fulfill our science objective but
before we can go here the moon we've got
to do for you a few more things I think
I think we're gonna I think I want us to
get into a stable orbit around kerbin I
want us to have a proper orbit rather
than just one of these trajectories it
takes us into space now again and I'd
like us to do a spacewalk I think so to
do that when you need some more money we
can need some more science I love this
game I love how pretty it is it's it's
it's why a lot of people in the comments
were saying how they'd always wanted to
be astronauts and everything and I can
completely amplifies with that
with a few like this why wouldn't you
want to be
Oh No
Apache failed donor I'm sorry
Oh
he's the seas now Oh God
oh man we have our first fatality and I
was so upbeat about I'm so sorry Jordan
it all went so badly I thought it went
really well and then it went really
badly this contrast was so much trouble
honestly why can't we take in this one
instead well like I did say I couldn't
promise anybody safety I didn't think it
would be quite that but look you could
see the debris from here oh that means I
can collect it okay a little bit money
okay so it's not all diamond Alima gasps
Jordan we're gonna go missing in action
oh dear
so before we cannot great the launchpad
I think the thing we need to do is we
need to upgrade the launchpad
so we can actually get into orbit but
not to do that we need lots of money so
we need to do a contract which is gonna
give us lots of money
this one was meant to do that but it was
a bit difficult for us this one however
this is the other one which is much
closer so let's do that it's much easier
now if anything we demonstrated that
this vehicle is a little bit too
powerful but I quite like it so I'm
never gonna run with it we're also gonna
have oh never forget
McGonigle
20:14 right let's put Ross marae in Ross
you wanted your [ __ ] to be cool
well I should no no you didn't give me a
ship name but I really let your username
so given that it's got accountant and I
thought it was appropriate you're gonna
be flying the cool five four three two
one
let's get some money we've got to be a
really cash focused Space Agency to fair
I think that's my Space Agency's right
so we're flying oh it's so close look at
that but right but we're now going we're
now going this way okay
get low explosive oh no I don't repeat
it last time no no no behave no right
stay there come on right there you go
no if anything mr. eshton to need to
burn in we want to go slightly northward
so he can do is actually literally just
point the ship north oh that's cool so
actually down tells us yes success right
estes jettison one mission that's all it
took this one can go screw itself
brilliant okay so that's just method us
a lot of money that's good right let's
just make sure that you get town safe to
the ground ross don't worry don't look
so worried I really don't to repeat at
last time come on I'm not gonna lose
another man his face
all right well we can actually do is we
can look at the altimeter in the the
crew capture there is a reason why you
have this view so just over a kilometer
out so let's deploy our parachute that's
the spacecraft that's gonna explode
what's your view like oh no you can see
the moon you can see the moon that's
cool and that's actually a point we can
use this display again almost there Oh
nearly there c'mon
there we go all right so this is good
rothmeyer got some Expedia's fantastic
right we still need more money what's
gonna give us lots and lots of money now
this one gives us quite a lot of money
so we have to mean a sub orbital
trajectory so that's what we've been
doing so far anyway we have to be pretty
high up and all we have to do is fire an
engine as high up as we've been so far I
think we can do that do you yeah come on
let's do it
so in order to do this then what we're
going to need to do is put another stage
on because we literally need a tiny
amount of fuel oh we got a new engine so
this is the one were supposed to be
testing I guess
the lv 909 yeah this one okay this is
like a small a smaller engine that you
would use on for example the leader
descent module or something but we have
to wait to fire it until we are over
something like seventy thousand meters
so if we have to be patient Ross didn't
get much time in the Sun did he right
tell you what Rocio an engineer useful
to have around
let's take you with us again there are
different engines for different purposes
right so what were using at the bottom
here look at that for a Segway is the
object is very very powerful heavy
engine
a large amount thrust burns feel very
quickly but this small duration that
we're going to test to there's something
they could use in December example
doesn't have as much there are they're
lost of in terms that you can use to
describe rocking engine see how specific
impulse you have
you to thrust
power-to-weight ratio oh okay you know
there's a whole bunch of terminology
oh no we're not losing another man
because you wouldn't want to guzzle up
all of you if it was landing because
there's literally no needs then why
would you bother taking a big heavy
engine that does that and this is
something which is represented in the
game when we do our look moon landing
which we are going to do that's that's
one of the big objectives I want to have
I will be using it and probably this
engine actually so just a slopper
testicle
now how are we
oh I think has to be behind us
what
No
separate oh wow okay now that could have
gone a lot better thanks for watching my
playthrough Kerbal space program this is
really the YouTube space program I
suppose this is where I am putting
youtubers and their spaceships into
space if you would like to be part the
Kerbal space program then please comment
below and I will add you to the roster
and equally if you have any ship names
or if you have a ship name that you
yourself would like to pilot please
comment down below and I will try and
get you in the game lastly if you have
any suggestions for topics I should talk
about over the top of gameplay when I
remember to then please also leave those
down below in particular I'm gonna be
looking at rocket science and rocket
history but if you think there's
anything else that would be relevant
please let me know thanks very much for
watching